i'm the alpha male and kate's the alpha
female and whatever you do never get
between a man and his dog
this afternoon's gonna be a really big
day for our puppy jack he's five months
almost six months old now
so gonna try to get him trained to
run along with the team if you don't
train these dogs up ahead of time you
can find yourself in a pretty bad
situation with no leaders and no trained
dogs
for jack today is about getting familiar
with running
in and around the team
and also starting to build confidence
gg
what's jack doing back there he's doing
good he's great
now he's gonna run up front
yay jackman
hey jackman he's the sled dog
come on buddy
come on get it come on jack
in a few more days i could put him in
just a small little team on the way home
and give him a little run in the harness
and see how he does
dogs are probably the most important
part of our lifestyle out here they
provide us with our transportation we
use them for freight for me probably one
of the most important things there's
they're my companions
okay burger boy
you ready to go up the eagle huh
you look so excited
yay
yay
got a boy straight ahead
right there okay everybody stay here
hey everybody
this year the river i scammed up right
to the bank
yeah there's a lot of halloways here
it's the stuff you got to worry about
with the dogs
right there they fall into that
that's when the shoulder gets blown out
jumbo ice poses a couple of different
problems uh
i can get through it
but it's very easy to hurt a dog when
you're going through rough jumble ice
and i'm really concerned about taking
care of my dogs because they're my
workforce they are
they are everything to me in the
wintertime making sure they don't get
hurt is
critically important to me
we'll try and go nice and slow through
this
ah boys okay let's go with the eagle
come on boys that'll boys
okay everybody whoa
whoa good job
good boy
you guys are trail breaking machines
okay enough let's go boys
yeah let's go
the dogs are our buddies but they're
also a tool they're a piece of machinery
and once i hook them up and go i know
i'm gonna make it to wherever i'm going
oh come on man
son of a [ __ ]
i'm gonna go hook up about 10 dogs and
we'll just drag it back to the shop with
the 10 dog and then go back with the
dogs and get a load of wood with them i
probably should have done that in the
first place
you guys ready to go
perform triple a services all right
let's go
that'll boys straight ahead straight
ahead come by let's go those 10 dogs ran
with that snow machine home and it was a
good feeling to see my dogs in shape
pulling the snow machine home with no
problems at all
atta boys
i don't want to rely on that equipment
anymore to do a quick job i'm going to
use my dogs because they're reliable